this is Afghanistan's latest enemy
locusts millions and millions of locusts
the country already has the worst
humanitarian situation in the world with
97 percent of the population living in
poverty but a massive Locust infestation
is like to make things even worse this
was a wheat field until a swarm of
locusts hit it
after collapse of the regimes
you know nobody pay attention to Locust
you know the Locust is a migratory
pressed and this is really dangerous
because they can attack even more than
100 species or crops you know in in the
country if Whenever there is nothing you
know they will eat everything the UN is
preparing for the worst their
predictions suggest up to 1.2 million
metric tons of Wheat and other crops
could be destroyed that's about a
quarter of Afghanistan's annual
production if you look at it in monetary
terms at today's rates that could be up
to 480 million dollars for a country
that doesn't have enough money or food
these insects could be devastating
the methods used to remove the locus may
seem primitive but it works they're
swept up in a giant tarpaulin the
previous government had spraying
capability but for reasons that aren't
clear this is not being used by the
Taliban the locusts here are destroyed
by pouring them into pits dug in the
ground and then covering them with soil
local farmers are being paid by the UN
agency to carry out the work it's some
money for families whose crops and
livelihoods have already been badly hit
I spoke to habibullah a farmer a local
Elder word
we are very annoyed by these locusts
they eat our grass and damages our
income in life they eat our crops the
wheat that we grow here is damaged by
the Locust since the Taliban took
control of the country nearly two years
ago Locus monitoring has lapsed and even
if these efforts mean the un's worst
fears aren't met this year things could
still get worse the locusts are
currently mating some are already laying
their eggs and experts say if left
untreated the numbers next year could
increase 100 fold James Bay's Al Jazeera
bagland Province Northern Afghanistan
and James joins us now live from Kabul
James